foreign
[Music]
a Long Island iced tea for me and Pepsi
please we only have Coke
no Percy he'll have a Long Island iced
tea too
am I allowed to be here oh yeah I know
the owner it's fine it's just that I'm
not
that doesn't matter here well I think
it's a federal law
I just hope my parents don't find out
that I'm here okay Long Island IC for
America's sweetheart
and one for the boy
oh
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
the new house is right on the water come
on dog you know how we do GNT with lime
we're not open until noon it is noon
it's 11 57. now what time is it 11 56.
[Applause]
good Lord you need to fire her I can't
fire she has a disability what no I
don't you don't no
Uber driver and I don't have a car
what up his parents said if I quote date
their son they'd give me a Buick Regal
you won't even rent your house out but
now you're going to rent out your badge
you have a roadrunner tattoo covering
your entire back I don't think you
should tell anybody what to do with
their body nope
I'm going to teach you how to have fun
am I allowed to be here I can't be
scared of everything your whole life
[__] Maddie Barker your little
disappearing act that was the best thing
that ever happened to me congratulations
is her vagina dishwasher safe she's a
real person what part of Russia do they
ship her from
she's Russian no [__]
up we're not a party have you seen Percy
Percy Percy Percy
doesn't anyone [__] anymore
[Music]
oh my god did you [__] him I like your
house a lot it's cozy ooh we should have
some music
dance party
switch
yeah this is good
are you
[Music]